when Jim Hensen and George Lucas worked
together they produced plenty of
wonderful content but fans didn't always
appreciate their work at the time
Labyrinth is one such film and it's
truly surprising it didn't do well the
film follows Sarah played by a young
Jennifer Connelly as she fights to
rescue her baby brother from the Goblin
King played by David Bowie who holds him
in his castle at the center of an
otherworldly Labyrinth Bowie provided
much of the film's music and dominated
every scene he was in Henson's work
shines through the many adorable and
frightening puppets appearing in nearly
every scene it's a true Gothic fairy
tale Venture film and it's magical but
sadly it bombed Labyrinth cost $25
million to make and audiences avoided it
preferring to see Top Gun or any of the
other better performing films released
in June
1986 despite tons of star power behind
it the film only took $14.5 million at
the global box office Labyrinth became a
hit by the Home Video Market though and
these days fans adore it as a cult
classic decades after its release
Labyrinth has expanded into a franchise
consisting of comics board games books
and more